[Música]
en los últimos siete días siete
ciudadanos rusos han sido detenidos por
la policía Noruega sospechosos de volar
drones ilegalmente por todo el país y
fotografiar en lugares restringidos lo
que lleva muchos a preguntarse Noruega
está siendo espiada por el kremlin se
han visto drones misteriosos volando
sobre varios aeropuertos incluido el
debergen en el sur del país donde
provocaron la suspensión del tráfico
aéreo durante dos horas otros drones no
identificados fueron vistos alrededor de
plataformas de perforación de petróleo
en el mar del Norte y también
sobrevolando esta planta de gas la más
grande de Europa desde os lo aseguraron
estar investigando los incidentes y que
no se puede descartar que se trate de
espionaje
[Música]
el departamento de contraespionajes
están cargando de la investigación de
estos casos afirman que estos incidentes
podrían apuntar a que Rusia está
asumiendo más riesgos en sus actividades
de espionaje tenemos que ser claros no
nos dejaremos intimida nos mantendremos
Unidos y con nuestros aliados y
apoyaremos a Ucrania
entre los rusos detenidos se encuentra
Andre y yakunin hijo de uno de los
Amigos íntimos de Vladimir Putin
arrestado por manejar un dron en la
remota Tundra desbal Aunque el sostiene
que estaba de vacaciones
una de las teorías es que los drones se
utilizan para avivar el miedo en torno
al suministro de gas de Noruega a Europa
las autoridades temen ser objetivo del
kremlin sobre todo después de
convertirse en la principal fuente de
gas de Europa por lo que han reforzado
los dispositivos de seguridad sin
embargo Rusia ha acusado a Noruega de
paranoia